[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous ici avons connu connaissons ou
allons connaître une rupture que ce soit
une rupture amoureuse que ce soit un
accident de la vie ou la perte d'un
proche tous un jour ou l'autre allons
faire face à une situation que l'on
pensait insurmontable alors la question
qui se pose c'est de quelle manière
pour vos mots pour vous nous pouvons
nous pardon surmonter quelque chose que
l'on pensait impossible pour vous parler
de rupture je vais inévitablement vous
parlez de la mienne et avant de vous
raconter mon histoire je vais vous
expliquer un petit peu quel garçon
j'étais donc j'étais un jeune garçon de
25 ans qui avait la vie devant lui et
qui était en man est en partie qui était
en management du sport en master à nice
et j'ai tendance à dire que ma vie était
partagé entre mon mode de vie donc un
mode de vie très sportif
les balades à moto les courses à pied le
long de la mer et les couchers de soleil
j'ai tendance à dire que j'avais une vie
pleine de vitamine d seulement voilà le
21 août 2017 alors que j'étais en
vacances chez mon papa
je prends la décision d'aller rejoindre
des amis sur la côte du côté de
seignosse pour aller passer quelques
jours de vacances
ce jour là c'est un jour d'été comme
beaucoup le connaissent c'est un jour
d'été où il fait chaud et je décide
d'aller me baigner pour ce qui devait
être la dernière fois de la journée je
me lève de ma serviette
je commence à trottiner le long de
l'océan je commence à trottiner le long
de l'océan et je plonge de main simple
hauteur seulement voilà je plonge dans
une eau qui est peu profonde
malheureusement le sable sous l'eau
c'est comme du béton à ce moment là je
me fracturé la cervicale c5 et je manque
de noyer j'étais en état de conscience
totale et je manque de noyer
c'était les secondes les plus longues de
ma vie il se passe 45 secondes une
minute et fort heureusement fort
heureusement à ce moment là j'ai mon ami
qui me sort de l'eau qui m'allonge sur
la plage et je lui explique que je ne
sens plus mes jambes
à ce moment là s'en suit la procédure
classique
j'ai les maîtres nageurs sauveteurs qui
arrive le long de la rive sur la plage
pardon je samu qui intervient et j'ai un
hélicoptère qui a atterri sur la plage
donc j'ai tendance à dire que c'était
digne d'un film et à ce moment là donc
je suis les porter à l'oea à l'hôpital à
l'hôpital de bayonne où je suis opéré
pendant sept heures et en fait on va me
retirer la cervicale c5 qui a été
fracturée et on m'explique
à ce moment-là que j'ai la moelle et y
épinière qui a été touché au niveau c6
c7
donc je profite de ce moment là comme
souvent quand j'ai l'occasion d'en
parler ou effectivement souvent on
associe la tétraplégie au film
intouchables ou c'est une personne
tétraplégique et une personne qui bouge
que la tête or c'est un petit peu plus
complexe que ça en fonction du niveau
vous allez toucher sur la moelle vous
allez avoir plus ou moins de
possibilités g
on qualifierait une tétraplégie passe
j'ai été touché au niveau c6 c7 et pour
faire simple sur le schéma qui est
derrière moi tout ce qui en verre
fonctionne mis à part mes doigts douma
tétraplégie skis en jaune en bleu et en
rouge ne fonctionne pas donc c'est pas
réalisé à ce moment là je me retrouve
donc en réanimation je resterai un mois
à l'hôpital et j'entame une année de
rééducation pour apprendre tous les
gestes du quotidien apprendre à composer
avec mon nouveau corps donc à ce moment
là je fais face évidemment à tout un tas
de questions car j'avais perdu tous mes
repères et je me retrouve à devoir
reposer des bases pour pouvoir rebondir
seulement voilà comment redonner du sens
à ce qui n'en avait plus et comment
accepter une situation qui est
inacceptable
j'ai tendance à dire que vous soyez en
situation de handicap ou même valide
pour avancer dans la vie il faut fixer
des objectifs des buts et moi mais
premier but à ce moment là c'était de
regagner en autonomie donc réapprendre
comme je le disais à recomposer avec les
gestes du quotidien du lavage de dents à
aller me doucher à m'habiller et ensuite
les autres objectifs
c'était la sortie du centre et la
reprise des études à ce moment là je me
à la sortie du centre je me confronte à
une nouvelle réalité cette réalité c'est
que je fais face à un monde qui n'est
pas forcément sensibilisé à la question
du handicap et j'ai dû non seulement
nous réapproprier mon rapport à la
société et mon rapport à l'autre car
avant évidemment j'interagis c'est avec
les gens du haut de mon mètre 80 mais 75
kg de muscles et de toute l'image que
j'avais construit par rapport à ça là je
dois interagir d'une autre manière
assis face à des gens qui me parlent
hauteur et forcément il y un rapport de
force qui va se créer même si ces
moments paraissait
difficile au final ce sont des moments
qui m'ont forgé et qui m'ont permis de
faire face à une réalité et donc
inévitablement à regagner confiance en
moi cette confiance en moi je n'aurais
pas pu certainement la guérir aussi vite
si je n'avais pas pu bénéficier d'un
outil que tout le monde utilise au
quotidien et ce sont les réseaux sociaux
les réseaux sociaux bien que l'on peut
trouver des points négatifs les réseaux
sociaux on était très important pour moi
les réseaux sociaux ont été une thérapie
par l'écriture car j'ai pu poser des
mots sur ce qui m'est arrivé
ça a été une thérapie par l'image car à
travers les photos j'ai pu reprendre
conscience de mon corps peut-être
magnifier ce nouveau mois que
j'apprenais à découvrir
mais au-delà de ça j'ai pu et j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir eu énormément de soutien
j'ai rencontré tout un tas de personnes
qui m'ont admis enfin adressé des
messages de bienveillance au quotidien
et tous ces messages au quotidien ont
permis de me donner de l'énergie me
donner de la force et de galvaniser des
choses en moi
dans ce lot de personnes qui m'ont
adressé des messages
j'ai aussi rencontré des personnes qui
ont fait face à la même tragédie que moi
quelques années auparavant et de la même
manière que ces gens ont rapporté des
éléments de réponses à des questions que
j'ai pu me poser
j'ai pu à mon tour donner des réponses
peut-être à travers mon témoignage à des
personnes qui ont faim qu'ils font face
aux mêmes difficultés que moi
aujourd'hui et c'est de là que
enfin c'est ce qui nous amène au point
suivant une responsabilité
pourquoi parce que j'ai cette chance
d'être entendue là où tant d'autres ne
sont pas entendus j'ai la chance d'avoir
des milliers de personnes qui me suivent
et peut-être peut-être adresser un
message d'espoir mais aussi un message
qui permet à travers mon témoignage
encore une fois de sensibiliser sur la
question du handicap de conscientiser
les personnes sur nos difficultés
je vais vous donner trois exemples qui
sont pour moi important est que j'ai
souvent l'occasion de donner je vous
parlais de l'exemple de l'architecte
admettons qu'une personne qui me suit
qui est architecte au lieu d'appliquer
et de conceptualiser pardon ses plans
selon les règles qui lui sont données
peut-être en faisant intervenir une
personne comme moi pour l'aider dans la
rédaction de ces plans peut-être que
cette personne va prendre conscience de
nos difficultés et un exemple que je
peux donner qui est le mien que je veux
quotidien j'ai emménagé dans un
appartement il ya six mois effectivement
cet immeuble est aux normes handicapés
et aux normes pmr mon appartement
l'immeuble seulement entre la réalité et
les normes il ya une grosse différence
car l'exemple qui est le mien les portes
sont beaucoup trop lourde pour une
personne en situation de handicap comme
moi moi j'arrivais à m'en sortir mais ce
n'est peut-être pas le cas pour d'autres
personnes
le second exemple que je peux vous
donner c'est admettons qu'une personne
qui a kiffé la location de vélos
peut-être que dans son parc de location
elle pourra mettre à disposition and
bike qui est un vélo spécifique pour les
personnes en situation de handicap et de
cette manière en mettant à disposition
ce type de vélo
cela me permettra d'accéder à un loisir
qui ne met pas accessible en règle
générale enfin le dernier exemple que je
peux vous donner c'est l'exemple du
boulanger qui peut évidemment
s'appliquer à d'autres commerces
peut-être que lieu de faire des travaux
très onéreux
un commerçant peut mettre à disposition
une rampe pliable moyennant un coût de
500 euros est peut-être mettre un
pictogramme sur la vitrine de son
commerce de façon en fait à rendre
accessible son commerce et de cette
manière là tous ces exemples que je peux
vous citer si les personnes prennent
conscience de nos difficultés peut-être
que ces personnes pourront être un
relais important et des aides pour aider
à ce que la société soit plus inclusive
car un point que j'ai failli oublier qui
est très important c'est que si vous
rendez mclean de société plus accessible
pour moi elle le sera inévitablement
pour d'autres et je mexplique ans et pan
prenons l'exemple d'une maman ou d'un
papa avec une poussette
si on rend la société plus accessible
pour moi inévitablement on va pouvoir
rendre la société plus accessible pour
des parents qui souhaitent
voilà accéder aux mêmes lieux que tout
nous est de la même manière que nous
allons tous vieillir un jour et donc
perdre en mobilité
si nous rendons la société accessible
pour une personne en situation de
handicap
nous allons aussi la rendre accessible
pour tout un tas de personnes de la
société 1 mais mantra est petit russe
aux formes les grandes rivières
j'aime cette phrase car pour moi
elle signifie que la somme de toutes les
individualités mise en commun permet à
la société de la rendre beaucoup plus
inclusif
l'image que je vous ai choisis à l'ap a
été choisi non plus au hasard
elle est pleine de symbolique nous
voyons là des oyats donc une plante qui
pousse sur les dunes et le réseau en
fait de racine que ça constitue permet
aux sables de ne pas s'envoler et donc
de permettre aux dunes de s'ériger face
à l'adversité ce nom les oyats c'est
aussi le nom que j'ai donné à une marque
que j'ai sorti la semaine dernière et
c'est une marque engagée où j'ai envie
en fait à tous les niveaux de celle ci
de faire quelque chose j'allais dire de
faire un pas pour le handicap des
assurés pas très contenue me concerne en
tout cas voilà c'est vraiment une marque
qui qui me permet d'aller de l'avant et
tout à l'heure je vous parlais
d'objectifs et donner du sens à sa vie
et je redonner du sens à la mienne
absent en temps utile pour la société et
je finirai avec une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup et qui me tient à coeur
qui de dire on est riche de soi à partir
du moment où on se sent utile pour les
autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]